MARK MIRCHANDANI: There
are lots of technologies
and communication that go
into building a smart city.
Join us in historic
downtown Austin, Texas,
as we talk to SoftServe
about using the cloud to make
smarter and safer cities.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
So what is a smart city?
RONALD ESPINOSA: That's the
question of the year, I think.
So for years, we had
the notion of "this
is the year of mobile."
And it feels like now it's "this
is the year of the smart city"
for the last couple of years.
And it means something
different to everybody.
I like to think of
them more in terms
of intelligent environments,
as opposed to smart cities,
because for one
city, becoming smart
might mean adding lights that
can get brighter or dimmer
as lighting outside changes.
It could be having
autonomous vehicles.
technologies and sensors
put in place to help
people with disabilities.
Really, what I
think it is, is it's
an environment that interacts
with the people that are inside
of that environment.
And that's why I
tend to drift more
toward an intelligent
environment, where
that could be a vehicle.
It could be a campus.
It could be a building.
It could be the space
that we have right now.
If we can be in two
places at the same time,
physically and
virtually, then I think
that's a smart environment.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Have
there been any examples
that you can talk about
of cities kind of creating
intelligent environments?
RONALD ESPINOSA: Sure.
So in the Carolinas Alliance for
Innovation out of Greenville,
South Carolina, we've got more
into the connected citizen
in the smart city
environment and
first-mile last-mile
transportation solves.
And what that is, is what
happens when you have five
or six different connected
and/or autonomous vehicles--
all different systems--
needing to speak to each
other, to the environment,
and traffic control
needs to be built?
And what we were able to
do was create a multi-modal
transportation, let's
call it, viewpoint--
single pane of glass,
control tower type of thing--
where we're able to see not
only where are the vehicles,
but what's the most efficient
mode of transportation,
from a cost standpoint,
for the connected citizen
to get from point A to point B?
And also, what's the
most efficient routing
for emergency services
vehicles and what-have-you?
Essentially, we're starting
to solve the big problem
that the public sector has
with digital technologies,
which is interoperability.
So how does one system
talk to another?
How do they bi-directionally
inform each other?
And we've been able to
do all of that in GCP.
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
And a lot of that
is based on, like
you just mentioned,
getting a lot of data,
being able to collect it.
What does all that technology
look like, especially when
it comes to Google Cloud?
RONALD ESPINOSA: When you have
just massive amounts of data
coming in and, really,
new sources of data
that maybe you hadn't
contemplated before,
it creates piles and piles and
piles of code to go through
and data files to go through.
And the simple fact is, is that
what used to take years to do,
can now be done in
minutes with BigQuery.
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
So a great example
of what this might
look like is collecting
from a whole bunch of
sensors, which is largely IoT.
But like you said,
that could be a tire.
That could be cars.
That could be traffic lights.
That could be anything.
Collecting all that
data, transforming it,
and making those data decisions,
especially the legal ones about
who owns which data, who
gets visibility into it--
making sure it all kind of
can play nicely together
by aggregating it, and then
ultimately doing analysis
on it.
RONALD ESPINOSA:
Yeah, I think so.
And really, I think the key term
here is "enablement" or even
"empowerment."
It's the idea that technology
took off at some point.
And the government was
focused on other things.
And now technology-- that
whole internet thing-- yeah,
it's not a thing.
It's here.
It's not going away.
And so now the government's in
a position where they say, well,
how do we manage it?
How do we tap into it?
And I think what's happening is,
Pandora's box has been opened
and saying, OK, well,
now it's opened.
Wow, we didn't know
all of this was here.
And as they implement
solutions, like smart lighting,
like smart cars, and
the connected citizen
becomes more and more
pervasive, well, now
what do we do with all this?
How do we manage it?
And then as they
drill into it, they
find out that this
is almost bottomless.
And we have to have something
that scales long-term.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Now,
there's a platform
that SoftServe offers
that kind of looks
at all of these aspects.
Can you tell us a little
bit more about that?
RONALD ESPINOSA: So we call it
the intelligent municipality
platform.
And essentially,
what that is, is it's
a data store built on GCP
that allows for collection
from myriad points of data,
export and connections
to any destination
so that we can enable
the public-private partnership
to work together and create
a digital ecosystem that
sits on top of this.
So we start out
with the basics of,
where is the data coming from?
How many different
systems do we have?
How do we put them in play
to work with each other?
And then from there, we
now start to say, OK,
what are the benefits?
Well, what if we can distill
things like amber and silver
alerts and get them
to the city corner,
as opposed to the entire zip
code when a message goes out?
So that's a public
service benefit.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Yeah, it
sounds like a lot of this
wouldn't have been
possible without some
of the advancements in the
cloud, especially recently.
RONALD ESPINOSA: I
think 100% impossible.
Where would you ever put
enough computing power
to make it happen?
MARK MIRCHANDANI: So both
because of scale and because
of the technologies
being offered,
but also some of the new--
like you mentioned
earlier about BigQuery
and being able to quickly
analyze huge amounts of data
very rapidly--
all of these things have
kind of enabled people
to ask, how can I improve?
Where can I use this data?
And how can I analyze it?
RONALD ESPINOSA: I think so.
I also think that the ease
of use, ease of access,
and, in a way--
and I'll use this
term abstractly--
a bit of standards.
There is a certain understanding
of what the Google Cloud
Platform is.
Use these tools to
do these things.
And you can have people
coming out of school,
ready to jump in and adopt this.
Well, that takes a lot
of the fear out of it
for a public sector entity,
and really for anyone.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Well, thanks
so much for coming in, Ron,
and telling us about how
SoftServe helps enable
companies, including
the public sector,
to really understand and
do more with their data.
RONALD ESPINOSA: Sure, I
appreciate the opportunity.
Thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
Thanks for joining us,
and stay tuned for more customer
interviews on Stack Chat.